people are great at having fun
today's topic what exactly are white
people superior at
well according to television everything
white man could fly
even a white woman she could be four
foot one she knew karate she could take
down 15 people
i like that girl that's my
mother right there i i love me a real
[ __ ] that's a real
i'm not gonna lie i do hate it when they
get this puny ass white girl and have
her doing all this crazy martial arts
i'm like
all right we get it mary sue they
actually have that's literally
the term for it you don't know huh what
are why people superior yet yeah
they do a better fish casual than any
one of us i wonder what you'll see
let's just watch the thing we'll see i'm
just curious i'm just trying to shift my
mind but i want to see if i can come up
with some original ideas before they
steal it
before they steal it yeah of course
before they steal it from the video that
was already
yeah yeah yeah cuz that's definitely i
said it first what
you're really good at colonizing oh yeah
yeah yeah i thought funny meme about
that yeah
name one thing that that feels canadian
but it's not
land
that was funny
fast food fat white people come with
some craziest fast food [ __ ]
yeah when they came up with the when
they came up with with
the bacon thing was it the baconator at
pfk
where it was two slices of chicken fried
chicken
with bacon in the middle and like the
buns it was shaky i was like wow you
yo they know what they're doing they
know how to create chains yeah
yeah whether it's on slaves or
restaurants yeah they know how to do
chicken
what are white people superior at
man
[Music]
oh god
man like making cereal casseroles what
kind of casserole tuna
it's always tuna what do you mean it's
always tuna
i'll give you that one that's pretty
good
give me that trip to seattle let's go
using
mayonnaise in a lot of their recipes
yeah
okay do we find that that's not white
this is americans that's americans
i like my fries with with mayo i'm like
oh
you know what makes me think of big head
and his mayonnaise in his head people
are great at having fun that's a
function
of white supremacy
oh you did not no no no no no
no we was having fun we were just having
our laughs
this is a function of white supremacy
under the umbrella
of the patriarchy white people have
found a way to inject
their privilege into every conversation
have you ever just been home
trying to enjoy yourself as a person of
color
and then all of a sudden different
shades enter your place
they enter your abode invading your
safe space and turning it into a war
zone a conflict
of colonization and as the white spirits
enter
and they come in with their fun all you
start to realize
is that you're no longer having fun and
you start to see
that what they truly came for is what
white supremacy
this is a swag because you know where
white people live right
where on the top layer because that's
where the whipped cream is and you know
what color whipped cream is right
all right and you know what cream is
right fun
yeah all right and so as they're out
there having fun and just applying
pressure onto the second layer
this is where some of the more
marginalized people live they're just
like oh my god what's all that noise
from the people upstairs are they having
a party and why people are like
yeah and so all of a sudden everyone
below it is just like oh
man gee what is going upstairs because
we're struggling down here and there are
no lights
and then you got the people on the third
layer those are our women
women they suffer too and you know what
i say about women right
they hold up half the sky guys give them
some credit snap the fingers yeah women
hold up half the sky
come on chant it with me guys women hold
up half the sky
oh man hold up half the sky women hold
all right all right all right and then
right below that we have our women
of color okay now listen ladies we
understand that you guys are ladies who
share the same genitalia with the
white devils but i feel like your
struggles is a little bit different
yeah what are white people superior at
let me tell you this is a multi-layered
question
yeah fearful of nothing being ignorant
blame
letting their egos control their every
move privilege truly killing victimized
playing the victim congratulating
themselves over that
they're incompetent at or that should
have already been done they're superior
at being
what exactly are white people superior
at oppression gaslighting
lack of empathy intellectualizing
oppression did i say oppression
they're just creatively thinking of new
ways of like always staying one step
ahead of other people we get
rid of slave catchers and let's just
expand the police force
this is me as uh as the the the video
progresses
muscles get lighter and lighter
you know i think there's a way you guys
could have done this video or it can be
fun
but i think the moment you guys get into
all these generals like why people are
just better at being afraid and better
being this i mean you're being serious
this kind of takes the the fun out of
the whole question like i thought it was
funny at first and i was having a laugh
yeah now i'm just like oh okay we get it
uh what's your problem abba is it too
real for you
we get it at first it was fun now it's
just real right yeah we get it you watch
michael eric dyson it's cool
congratulations reflected in the
dominant white society
refracted through the prism of our own
black lives
matter such people are parapathetic that
is walking around
virtuous not in terms of their virtue
but
virtuous virtual expressions of degraded
self-hatred i feel sorry i feel horrible
when i'm in the presence of such mean
speaking
ignorance spewing incredibly
cantankerous viewpoints
that don't honor the integrity the
beauty the diversity the complexity
and the wondrous rapturous intelligence
of black this
is a multi-layered question yeah this is
what i'll say you know what
what's the point of this rhetoric what's
the point of the video
right what what's the point of this i
was about to ask the question the same
question
i'm like okay i don't understand what
the point is of like bringing up a
difficult topic such as like
you know the race relations and things
like that and then having people answer
in two three words
now look maybe the people had like more
nuanced answers but obviously you can't
fit them in because 100 people and it's
a stupid concept but like
why would you tackle such a serious and
like serious thing and then have like
elevator music playing
and then have people give two word
answers you're bound to fail this is so
stupid
well it's not so much that they gave two
words answers is
what the montage the editing at the end
they cut out
one or two yeah that's what i'm saying
but yeah the way the way the
the way they edited that is it was
really just
it was really edited in like one or two
words i'm pretty sure the people said
much more than that
what was the point i don't know yeah
maybe they wanted to see what people
or what let's just ask the question and
see where the video takes you it takes
us right what let's see what the answers
of the people where people
take us with their answers but if that's
what you actually want to do
actually let the people take you
somewhere with their answers if you just
edit it to one
word that's being descended always but
that's just me yeah
i just um i don't it's conceptually i
think they just kind of miss the mark
with that
if you're not going to have the
discussion in a nuanced way why have it
listen i love making food right
quite enjoyed
making ethiopian dishes is quite
complicated
if you tell me that you want to make
ethiopian dishes but then you remove all
the spices that are required to make the
dish
then you're not making anything food and
just don't waste your time like if
you're not willing to put in the work
and get the right ingredients to make
the dish
then go somewhere else and make
something different
same thing with this conversation if
you're not really willing to like try to
unpackage things and try to bring them
in a way that's interesting
why have this conversation who is this
for
is it for yourselves to feel better and
be like oh my god look we were able to
point out how white people are superior
in such a corny ass way especially like
during this pandemic
all this identity politics has really
just bore the [ __ ] out of me yeah
especially it's always the same thing i
don't care about the fact that we're
having a discussion or not because
having a discussion is important it's
just that
the way they're having a discussion
nothing comes out of it
we don't have a solution we don't
understand each other better we just
point point point
no understanding you know so
yeah having a discussion let's have a
discussion
i'm all for it let's go we're having a
let's talk the problem is that that's
that was not a discussion
that was a question editing one or
one one or two word answers and that's
pretty much what it was
can we like just add something more
interesting to this conversation
no because okay you say why you're evil
what am i
if i was a white person what am i going
to do with that with that information
because i personally don't feel evil so
so what are you
saying yeah but you benefit from white
supremacy okay how
you didn't cover it yeah but you guys
benefit from wet and whiteness okay how
you didn't cover it you're evil okay
what do you want me to do people in my
day-to-day life tell me i'm a good
person so what do i change
you're a liar you know it's just like so
it's just
a waste of time
[Music]
is